une passion française la pétanque anime
les beaux jours français depuis des
siècles
[Musique]
ce sport est typique du midi mais la
france entière le pratique avec des
variantes selon les régions
les adeptes se sont fédérés en 1945
année de la création de la fédération
française de pétanque et de jeu
provençal
il est certain que ce soit en les
marchés y est tout à fait les mêmes les
provençaux qui ont apporté ce jeu à
paris mais qui maintenant cet institut
et en sport et s'est organisée d'une
façon merveilleuse dans la région
parisienne
vous voulez dire que ce sont les
parisiens qui ont fait de ce jeu un
sport mais bien entendu on doit
certainement beaucoup aux parisiens de
s'être mis à ce jeu est devenu un sport
preuve que les parisiens ne rigole pas
avec la pétanque
cette archive de 1961 un arrêté
municipal interdit la pratique dans les
bois de vincennes et de boulogne et les
joueurs ils ont les boules suis désolé
qu'il soit parisien marseillais ou
d'ailleurs les boulistes français ont su
montrer que leur sport mais pâques du
folklore stratégie concentration
entraînement en 2003 la pétanque est
reconnu par le ministère des sports ce
que ça change
l'arrivée de sponsors et de nouvelles
subventions
je pense pas qu'il faille le voir que
sur le plan financier je crois qu'il
faut le voir aussi sur le plan de
l'image et et surtout de la
reconnaissance des athlètes de la
craindre des dérives du type dopage le
problème qu'il ya c'est que tous les
joueurs de pétanque sont dopés malin
pouvoir tous du pastis interdit de faire
jouer les jeunes et pourtant la blague
était prémonitoire
huit ans plus tard en 2011 un scandale
de dopage éclatement la pétanque
française des joueurs ont été
sanctionnés pour usage de bêtabloquants
la substance permet de limiter les
tremblements
paraît-il que ça se fait qu'on vous
n'avez jamais rien pris pour avoir la
pêche moi je prends mon lit quand même
de la gelée royale quelques sanctions
pour des cases isolé et la faire c'est
vite fait oublier
l'an dernier la pétanque rassemblé 300
mille licenciés sans compter les
milliers de boulistes légion dans nos
parcs et jardins tous les étés
[Musique]